wie groß ist die Vorfreude auf diese
winter-wm irgendwie bin ich kalendarisch
über viele WMS die ich selber begleiten
durfte und wo ich wo ich vor Ort war bin
ich so auf diese Mitte des Jahres gepolt
dass mich das noch nicht aber es wird
wird's losgeht wenn man sich egal
ach ich freue mich auf auf Fußball den
ich sehen werde aber ich freue mich
natürlich nicht so wie ich mich gefreut
hätte wenn es all die Diskussion drum
nicht gegeben hätte weil die kann ich
nicht ausblenden will ich auch nicht
ausblenden aber andererseits werde ich
sicher auch Fußball gucken du bist
gucken aber nicht hinfahren nein nicht
hinfahren weil ich beruflich anders
wer hier aus der Runde wird hinfahren
ich werde tatsächlich hinfahren aus dem
Grund weil ich mich einfach seit vielen
vielen Jahren mit dem Land und mit der
Region beschäftige vor drei Wochen noch
in Katar war und mit vielen Leuten
gesprochen habe und deswegen tatsächlich
auch gucken will was ist vor Ort dann
wirklich los wenn man sich so viel und
so intensiv mit der WM und mit Katha
beschäftigt hat wo werden sie herrettich
das Eröffnungsspiel gucken das glaube
ich weil was ist das öffnungsspiel Katar
gegen Ecuador
also geplant ist eine
Gegenveranstaltung in Kölner Kneipen so
dass ich in einer Kölner Kneipe schauen
werde aber kein Fußball sondern wir
werden über andere Dinge philosophieren
bei einem guten Kölsch und die es gibt
ja mittlerweile eine Bewegung nicht nur
in Köln mittlerweile bundesweit dass
viele Kneipenwirte gesagt haben bei mir
gibt es kein Fußball während der WM und
da werde ich Umsatz machen das heißt sie
werden gar kein Spiel gucken ich bekenne
mich schuldig dass meine
Fußballleidenschaft größer sein wird als
die Vernunft die deutschen Spieler
gucken Moment sie gucken sie
boykottieren das aber die deutschen
Spiele gucken sie deswegen sage ich es
ist nicht ganz konsequent deswegen kenne
ich ganz konsequent ist gut ist gar
nicht nein ist es nicht deswegen sage
ich ja auch ich wollte nicht dann auch
stehen und heimlich zu Hause gucken ich
werde es gucken die deutschen Spiele
aber mehr auch nicht okay jetzt kommt
die ganz harte Frage wenn die Deutschen
im Finale stehen fahren Sie hin oder
nicht sie sind eingeladen als als
langjähriger Funktionär auch nein also
über den Schatten kann ich in der Tat
nicht springen ich habe den letzten
Weltmeistertitel der deutschen
Mannschaft live in Rio mein Leben dürfen
das war für mich was ganz Besonderes das
muss man auch sagen aber dass ich mir
ein Fußball spielen in Katar anschaue
also soweit geht die fußballliebe dann
doch nicht Lena wie werden sie es halten
Vorfreude auf diese Weltmeisterschaft
ist ja spannend dass wir alleine jetzt
darüber reden ob meine Weltmeisterschaft
gucken ist eigentlich das wirklich
verrückte ist normalerweise würden wir
jetzt hier Sitzung wissen wer
Fußballweltmeister ist ne das kommt noch
dazu daran merkt man wie anders alles
ist plötzlich natürlich und natürlich
habe ich mir die Frage auch gestellt
schaue ich das schaue ich das nicht man
befindet sich in so einem moralischen
Dilemma halte es da aber auch wirklich
mit Marcel Reif man sollte das ganze
nicht moralisch überfrachten und auch
auf den Endkonsumenten abwälzen ich
finde das komplett in Ordnung wenn sich
jemand dafür entscheidet zu sagen ich
boykottiere das weil ich das mit meinem
Gewissen nicht vereinbaren kann ich habe
überlegt wie Hand habe ich ich habe
gesagt ich will ein lauten Protest
machen ich finde wegsehen das ist mir zu
wenig ich finde der Laute Protest der in
den letzten Monaten und Wochen ja auch
wirklich sehr sehr sehr massiv war der
hat was dafür gesorgt dass die
Missstände offengelegt worden also dass
man laut war dass man nicht sich einfach
für vier Wochen zu Hause verkriecht und
die die Spiele nicht gucken man kann das
nutzen das ist auch eine Chance
weiterhin auf die Missstände aufmerksam
zu machen Andreas Rettich hat jetzt
gerade angekündigt vielleicht ein
bisschen was einsammeln Spenden sammeln
auch das eine Möglichkeit wir haben
täglichen Podcast wo wir Fußball
berichten haben auch überlegt machen wir
das einfach so Blanco wie wir das sonst
immer machen oder probieren wir
vielleicht einen Spendentopf zu
errichten und zumindest was den
Entrechteten und den Opfern der Familien
was zurückzugeben das ist nämlich glaube
ich jetzt das Mindeste dass man einen
entschädigungsmechanismus findet ich
habe mich für den lauten Protest
entschlossen dabei ich bin komplett fein
damit wenn sich jemand der anders dazu
entscheidet aber auch das nicht schauen
trifft die die diese Art des
sportswashing betreiben wenn viele das
eben die Glotze schwarz lassen damit sie
da das Treffen in der Frage diese
romantische Vorstellung habe ich
zumindest Sponsoren werden sich
möglicherweise in der Nachbetrachtung
Fragen investiere ich mein Geld bei
solchen Veranstaltungen die wichtig
gesellschaftlich abgelehnt wird das
glaube ich schon da können wir jeder im
kleinen dazu beitragen
also Ralf wollte gerade nee ich glaube
nur nicht dass das den Erfolg haben wird
den es haben müsste damit diese Art des
Protest funktioniert Einschaltquoten
sind ich bin lang genug in der im
beruflichen dem Geschäft Einschaltquoten
sind hilfreich bei Entscheidungen in
welche Richtung auch immer und mangelnde
Einschaltquoten sind ganz besonders
hilfreich aber ich fürchte
dass das wird nicht sein aber noch mal
das ist dann wenn das eine persönliche
Entscheidung eines bin ich völlig bei
ihm völlig ich wollte nur eins zu der
Einsatz bemerken diese gemacht haben
melanz zu Marcel in der Frage was für
eine Verbesserung erzielen soll Katar
und dann wäre man bereit zu schauen oder
den Daumen zu heben oder Weg zu bleiben
ganz ehrlich also mir ist kein
sportliches Großereignis bekannt was am
Ende gesellschaftliche Missstände im
Nachgang abgestellt hat oder wo es zur
verbessern gekommen ist und deshalb sind
auch so viele verärgert und enttäuscht
weil es wird ja immer mit dem
Deckmäntelchen ja durch die
Weltmeisterschaft wird etwas passieren
was soll da passieren ja in der Frage
und es sind eben eine tote dort
entstanden durch die WM und sie sind nur
deshalb ins Bewusstsein gerückt weil
eben viele laut waren und die
Öffentlichkeit dahin geschaut hat und
jetzt das zu drehen und zu sagen aber es
wird Verbesserungen gegeben also ganz
ehrlich da fehlen
damit wir sozusagen alle über das
gleiche reden
was genau bemängeln sie was genau
beklagen sie was werfen sie Katha vor
den Vergabeprozess da ist Kataria
bedingt schuldig in anderen Abführung
der überhaupt in 2010 wie die 2010
gekommen
FIFA um das mal klar zu sagen man muss
sich auf der Zunge zergehen lassen im
Dezember 2010 ist entschieden worden
eine Austragung einer Weltmeisterschaft
im Sommer muss bis zu 50 Grad werden
können sie können bei 50 Grad kein
Fußball spielen das ist ausgeschlossen
ja lassen sich mal von den
Leichtathleten bei der WM erklären die
gesundheitsgefährdend die Situation bei
der WM der Leichtathletik in Katar war
da haben 22 Herren Frauen waren nicht
reif für so eine Entscheidung hatte ich
den Eindruck haben entschieden dort die
WM hinzugehen wenn du ganz kurz für für
Interessierte und für Feinschmecker wie
viele von diesen 22 sitzen aktuell im
Knast oder haben Verfahren an der Hacke
sicherlich über ein Drittel
wahrscheinlich also es sind viele ja ein
größerer Teil in jedem größerer Teil
deswegen kann man sie auch schlecht
befragen weil sie einige im Knast sitzen
aber andere auch gestorben sind andere
auch gestorben aber die haben dann ihr
Geheimnis mit ins Gespräch bestechlich
waren ja die auch nachweislich aber ich
wollte nur sagen der Frust richtet sich
ja in erster Linie auf dieses System und
diesen Vergabeprozess weil letztlich
jeder wusste es war die schlechteste
Bewerbung ja bel die Expertenkommission
hat Katar eben die Platzreife nicht
zugesprochen in der Frage klimatischen
Dinge sind bekannt es wurde rucha das
Korruption im Spiel war und wenn man
sich dann die geografische Situation
anschaut das ungefähr so groß wie
Schleswig-Holstein ja ich stelle mir vor
ich bin eine Produktion bei der Vergabe
und FIFA das ist ja jetzt keine
exklusive Angelegenheit von Katana aber
das mache ich sag mal Deutschland 2006
wie frei von allem war das ja
einverstanden aber das macht sie nicht
besser wir können ja nicht das Unrecht
gegen das Unrecht aufnehmen aber wenn
wir jetzt so argumentieren im Sommer so
wenn wir da mit dem Finger auf Katar
zeigen zeigen zehn Finger auf uns zurück
ja und nicht nur auf uns nein aber Katar
und und dabei zu bleiben warum der Frust
so groß ist weil es hier am Ende gegen
alle Vernunft gegen Themen die auch
gerade wenn man über das Thema
Menschenrechte sprechen dann nehmen wir
die zweite im zweiten Baustein dazu
man muss ja
2010 ist die Vergabe durchgeführt worden
und 2011 ist das diskutierte
kavala-system ins Leben gerufen worden
weil menschenverachtend ist in der Frage
das kann man erklären was das ist ja
gerne und das heißt ein Jahr danach und
die FIFA ist der Hauptschuldige an
dieser ganzen Problematik weil sie es
versäumt hat eben keine
menschenrechtsvorgaben in der
Bewerbungsprozess mit aufzunehmen das
ist der kapitale Fehler und wenn ich die
Bilder sehe auch jetzt hier von Herrn
Blatter oder noch die Steigerung wird
der hat ja gedacht es geht nicht mehr
schlimmer aber Herr Infantino übertrifft
ja noch alles weitere ist auch zu
befürchten dass er irgendwann von Doha
nach Riad demnächst umzieht in der Frage
was die instantin oder aktuelle
FIFA-Präsident der im Haus in Doha hat
dort lebt gerade oder er lebt da
momentan ist Schweiz umgezogen ich
glaube weil von dort die Geschäfte
besser zu tätigen sind also da fehlen
einem schon interessant die Worte ja und
man hört immer es wird die beste WM und
die schönste WM das haben wir alle
Präsidenten immer erklärt okay aktuelle
ist immer die beste okay die die cafala
System reden wir gleich drüber die die
Zustände die sie sonst beklagen also die
Toten Arbeiter die es offensichtlich
gegeben hat die Zustände in diesen
Unterkünften die Bezahlung die
Menschenrechtssituation
wann waren Sie das letzte Mal Katar
ich war noch gar nicht in Katar aber ich
denke auch weil das ja so ein Thema ist
man kann ja nicht nur Dinge beurteilen
wenn man vor Ort gewesen ist ich war
auch noch nicht in Nordkorea und ich
denke dass ich mir trotzdem ein Urteil
darüber erlauben kann wie es dort
aussieht gut ist natürlich schwieriger
nach Nordkorea reinzukommen also live
glaube ich war schon mal Nordkorea ne
weil ich richtig im Kopf glaube ich ne
haben wir darüber gesprochen trotzdem
immer die Frage also sozusagen sie sie
Fällen da dieses Urteil obwohl sie da
noch nie waren ja aber ganz ehrlich die
Zahlen und die Fakten sind ja relativ
klar was was soll ich in was soll ich in
Katar ich meine Beckenbauer hat auch
keine Sklaven gesehen ja also von daher
denke ich ist das eine Reise die ich mir
sparen kann und wenn man die seriösen
nach ihren Erkenntnissen wie viele
Menschen sind dort gestorben beim Bau
dieser Stadion das kann seriös niemand
beantworten das ist ja genau eine der
Probleme zum Beispiel zum Beispiel weil
letztlich wir eine Dunkelziffer von über
70 Prozent der Todesfälle haben da wird
gar keine Autopsie durchgeführt das
heißt
alles Vermutung daran möchte ich mich
die beteiligen in der Frage aber warum
lässt man das im Ungewissen weil nach
dem menschenrechtsvorgaben ja
Verantwortung für dann die FIFA oder
auch für Katar gewesen wäre wenn man das
Zuordnen hätte können dann werden
nämlich Entschädigungszahlungen fällig
das heißt da besteht ja kein Interesse
daran zu sagen das ist keine
entschädigungsprobleme tut mir
eingefallen dass uns nicht
tote gegen tote aufregen lass uns nicht
sagen es sind doch ein paar wenige okay
dann ist es ja halb so wild oder es im
Meer dann ist es ja wichtig schlimm
jeder jeder Tote ist ist einer zu viel
das lass uns nur damit es nicht so nein
aber das ist die Diskussion um die
Anzahl der Todesopfer tatsächlich auch
die geht in eine falsche oder in eine
unpräzise Richtung die Frage die Frage
ich danach weil es gibt so viele wenn
man sich mal anfängt und ich meine das
ganz
wertfreien warum ich warum ist aber lass
uns doch mal den Versuch machen weil was
ich immer wieder sehe ist es werden
immer wieder zahlen abgeschrieben weiter
kolportiert es werden viele viele
Gerüchte immer wieder weiter
transportiert ich erlebe selber komme
vielleicht gleich noch drauf eine
gewisse Scheinheiligkeit auf politischer
Ebene also speziell auch hier in dieser
Sendung was dieses Thema angeht und
deswegen frage ich so explizit danach
und würde sie gerne her Fragen also uns
was weiß man denn darüber sie haben viel
Zeit dort verbracht ja also die Frage
wie viel Tote sind tatsächlich gestorben
lässt sich seriös nicht beantworten im
Raum stehen dann sind das keine
gesicherten zahlen oder
die von den Kartagen Behörden
rausgegeben werden und es gibt zum
Beispiel die Zahl die auch der Guardian
dann verwendet hat 15.000 tote zwischen
2010 und
2011 und 2019 diese Zahlen sagen nur aus
dass in diesem Zeitraum 15.000 Menschen
ums Leben gekommen sind ohne die
Todesursache da gebe ich ein Rettich
absolut recht es geht darum woran sind
die Menschen gestorben und es geht vor
allen Dingen auch um einem zweiten Punkt
der wichtiger ist als die Anzahl es geht
darum dass wir bei Ausbeutung von
Arbeitsmigranten um ein globales
strukturelles Problem sprechen es geht
darum dass Menschen in Katar ausgebeutet
werden aber bereits schon in ihren
Heimatländern in Pakistan Bangladesch
die Menschen leben in großer Armut unter
anderem für unsere Textilindustrie zu
sagen genau das ist ein Thema es geht
darum dass ich diese Menschen
verschulden müssen bei kriminellen
rekrutierungsagenturen die sie dann erst
nach Katar bringen teilweise müssen die
ihr Hab und Gut ihr weniges haben und
gut veräußern damit sie überhaupt das
Geld aufbringen können nach Katha zu
kommen und dann kommen sie in gewisser
Art und Weise vom Regen in die Traufe ob
das jetzt Cutter ist Saudi-Arabien ist
die Vereinigten Arabischen Emirate das
kafala-system sie hatten es gab schon
angesprochen ist sozusagen dann ist der
Mechanismus
arabisch oder auf Deutsch ist arabisches
Wort heißt auf Deutsch so viel wie
Vormundschaft oder Bürgschaft das heißt
ein katarischer saudischer
Staatsangehöriger hat die Möglichkeit
ausländische ArbeitsmigrantInnen
anzustellen und hat dann auch die
verfügungsarbeit in großer in großen
Bereichen über diese Menschen die heißt
Pässe konfiszieren verbieten dass man in
die Sender ausreichend rausreißt dass
man in seine dass man seinen Arbeitgeber
wechseln darf sie bestimmen vor einigen
im häuslichen Bereich ein ganz großes
Problem darüber wie lange Menschen
arbeiten müssen teilweise 17 18 Stunden
7 Tage die Woche sie können Löhne
vorenthalten und so weiter das kapitaler
System ist tatsächlich ein sehr sehr
langes Prinzip dass ich in der
arabischen Welt nicht nur in Saudi
Arabien kann
etabliert hat die die Wurzeln gehen auf
ein beduinisches auf beduinisches
Gewohnheitsrecht zurück dass man sagt
wir wollen eigentlich unsere fremden
schützen also es geht eigentlich erstmal
um um eine gewisse Gastfreundschaft dass
man als Bürge auch für jemanden birgt
der bei einem zu Gast ist und das wurde
dann sozusagen pervertiert genau und das
bringt mich zu dem letzten Punkt von dem
kavala-system profitieren einfach
unglaublich viele Menschen die damit
wahnsinnig viel Geld verdienen warum
erklären Sie das einmal weil man zum
Beispiel allein aufgrund seiner
katarischen Staatsangehörigkeit die
Möglichkeit hat Migranten zu rekrutieren
ohne dass man vielleicht digitale
braucht sondern man kann dann auf dem
Markt in Katar Menschen transferieren
für eine gewisse Vermittlungsgebühr und
damit verdient man Geld dass das eine
die rekrutierungsagenten die in Nepal in
Bangladesch im Pakistan unterwegs sind
um Leute zu rekrutieren sind einfach
kriminell oftmals und nehmen sehr viel
Geld diesen Menschen ab das ist
sozusagen der zweite die zweite große
Gruppe die davon profitiert und wir
dürfen einzig vergessen die Länder die
Regierungen aus denen diese Menschen
kommen sind meistens sehr sehr arme
Länder und sie sind diese Regierungen
sind darauf angewiesen dass Migranten
das Geld dann ihre Familien
zurücküberweisen die sogenannten
Rücküberweisungen 25% weltweit aller
Rücküberweisungen kommen aus den
Golfstaaten ein Land wie Nepal hat 25
Prozent seiner Einkommen im
Bruttoinlandsprodukt allein aus diesen
Rücküberweisungen wenn man das von heute
auf morgen unterbinden würde und
Migranten nicht mehr gehen würden also
diese Flucht aus der Armut nicht mehr
stattfinden würde während diese Länder
Pleite Staatsbankrott und deswegen haben
ist das nicht nur Katar ist ein
Puzzleteil ist ein ganz wesentlicher
positiv und die Kritik im Vorfeld der WM
ist deswegen auch so wichtig dass man
sagt wir gucken genauer hin wie
strukturelle Ausbeutung von Migration
stattfindet und von Migranten aber es
ist eben auch nur ein Puzzleteil sondern
wir reden klar das ist bei Migration
immer so über ein transnationales
grenzübergreifendes Phänomen da gehen
Menschen genau Geld das Migranten von A
nach B überweisen das haben wir doch
hier auch also in Europa viele
afrikanische Staaten würden kollabieren
wenn die Afrikaner die hier in Europa
mittlerweile sind nicht sehr viel Geld
zurück nach Hause schicken würden und
das ist ein globales Phänomen genau das
ist auch ein Problem von einer
kapitalistischen Gesellschaft wo
Menschen ausgebeutet werden das ist
nicht so rechtfertigen und auch nicht
gut zu reden und Cutter steht dafür
jetzt auch zu Recht in der Kritik aber
es ist wie gesagt ein Symptom eines
Systems was richtig vielen vielen Jahren
existiert aber dieses kavala-system ist
natürlich trotzdem noch mal eine ganz
besondere das vereinbartierte Art
es ist eine Person die modernes
Sklaventum was anderes ist es nicht
menschliches Organisationen sprechen
davon dass
und es gibt mit Sicherheit dafür gute
Belege es gibt in der Tat auch andere
Elemente des verfallersystems aber die
ausbeuterischen überwiegen und das hat
damit zu tun dass die Hierarchie
zwischen den Menschen die die Macht
haben und den Menschen die die Macht
nicht haben absolut groß ist und für die
Menschen die keine Macht haben auch
keine Wahlmöglichkeit besteht so und
trotzdem sagen Sie es wäre falsch das zu
boykottieren warum
auch da bin ich bei bei Ihnen dass jeder
das für sich selbst entscheiden sollte
es ist eine individuelle Entscheidung
wenn man sich über die richtigen Gründe
Gedanken macht also ich boykottiere eine
WM weil ich unzufrieden bin mit der
Korruption im Fußball ist das absolut
nachvollziehbar ich finde es ebenso
nachvollziehbar wenn man sagt die
Ausbeutung von ArbeitsmigrantInnen kann
ich moralisch absolut nicht vertreten
und dieses Turnier steht dafür
sinnbildlich wenn es aber darum geht
darüber zu diskutieren dass es eine
winter-wm ist dass man da eventuell kein
Bier trinken kann dann finde ich dieses
Argument problematisch einfach weil man
dann einer Region nämlich der arabisch
muslimischen Welt abspricht Teil der
Fußballfamilie zu sein was ich meine ist
und was wir stärker diskutieren sollten
ist dieser globale Anspruch auch an uns
dass wir sagen die das was in Katha
passiert passiert nicht nur dort und wir
haben eine Verantwortung der Sport hat
eine Verantwortung die Politik wir
Menschen haben eine Verantwortung darauf
aufmerksam zu machen und zum Beispiel
eben auch zu schauen wie sieht es in den
entsende Ländern aus was passiert denn
mit Familien die teilweise
jahrzehntelang ihre Ehemänner meistens
sind ja Männer ihre Väter ihre Söhne gar
nicht sehen was passiert wenn der auf
einmal stirbt wenn der kein Geld mehr
überweisen kann da gehen Existenzen zu
hoch ich muss da noch mal deshalb
einhalten weil der Sport kann nicht zu
gesellschaftlichen Veränderung führen ja
das ja ich denke das Bett gleich noch
mal besprechen weil es ein wichtiger
Punkt bei allem was wir jetzt bereden an
welches das das der Zeitpunkt an welchem
setzen wir an setzen wir an bei der
Vergabe oder setzen wir an in in einem
Monat oder jetzt wie sieht's nicht hier
gemütlich was ich nicht möchte ist dass
wir in einem Studio gemütlich in Studien
sitzen und sagen auch das finde ich das
sollte aber anders sein das wird die
müssten das jetzt so machen sondern an
welcher Stelle dem die macht damit die
Machtfrage die FIFA hatte die Macht beim
vergabeprotest da hast du die Macht zu
sagen ihr wollt es
aus welchen Gründen auch immer ihr
kriegt es wenn und dann müsste es ein
Katalog geben der unter anderem und
nicht zuletzt dieser oder in dem Moment
wo du das aufgibst und sagst die WM ist
vergeben jetzt geht es darum wie gehen
wir damit um und
werden hier heute nicht die Welt
verändern ich bin ich finde es trotzdem
gut dass wir mal versuchen diese
Grautöne auch mal ein bisschen zu
beleuchten und wenn es dazu führt dass
man am Ende ein bisschen nachdenklicher
von diesem Fernseher sitzt wenn man sich
vielleicht das deutsche Finale anguckt
das ist ja auch ganz gut Lena Kassel
sagt diese WM konterkariert sozusagen
alles wofür der Fußball in den letzten
Jahren gestanden hat was heißt das man
hat sich natürlich für gewisse Werte
aktiv eingesetzt man wurde ja nicht dazu
gezwungen sich die regenbogenbinder
angefangen wann hat die FIFA sozusagen
die die Idee das auch Menschenrechte
wichtig sind
das erste Mal sozusagen in ihre Statuten
aufgenommen
nach der WM-Vergabe fünf Jahre nach der
Vergabe spielt ihr vorher keine Rolle da
war immerhin also ich will sagen die
Diskussion hat ja dann offensichtlich
dazu geführt dass sich da was bewegt hat
das oder will ich ihn widersprechen
errettich nein aber Entschuldigung ganz
kurz vor Kassen zu Ende
drehen wir es mal um das Gefälle ich
liebe die Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft
jeder Fan liebt die
Fußball-Weltmeisterschaft jeder Spieler
liebt die Fußballweltmeisterschaft es
ist ein verbindendes Element wenn
unserer Gesellschaft im Kleinen mit
Familie und Freunde aber auch im großen
wer hätte denn gedacht dass Deutschland
mal für ein weltoffenes fröhliches
multikulturelles Land steht das hat die
WM 2006 geschafft deshalb sprechen wir
über ein Sommermärchen das heißt für
mich ist eine Fußballweltmeisterschaft
auch immer ein Brennglas dafür was für
eine Wirkmacht der Fußball in ganz
positiven Sinne hat eine Strahlkraft
Menschen hinter einer Idee zu versammeln
ja und und
häufig nicht mehr schaffen genau richtig
und deshalb ist dieses Gefälle was ich
aktuell in mir spüre so wahnsinnig weil
ich habe das Gefühl das was da jetzt in
Katar passiert das konterkariert alles
was der Kern des Fußballs eigentlich für
mich persönlich ausstrahlt ich bin mit
dem Fußball sozialisiert worden seitdem
ich vier bin fußball ist für alle da die
Kabine ist das bunteste Tor da ist es
egal wer irgendwie aussieht wie er ist
was er mag was er nicht machen Leistung
zählt und das ist auch unter fehlt mir
so ein bisschen auch wenn wir jetzt mal
über Bayern München redet dass mia san
mia des Fußballs wir haben ein
Selbstverständnis der Fußball steht für
eine gewisse Kultur Darauf sind wir
stolz und jetzt bei dieser WM ging es
vielleicht auch mal darum diese Werte zu
verteidigen moralische Standards zu
verteidigen die sind nicht dehnbar wenn
der Preis stimmt
in der Konsequenz können wir sagen von
2010 bis 2022 sind 12 Jahre vergangen
das heißt selbst wenn es die naive
Absicht gab wir wollen was vor Ort
verändern wir wollen die arabische Welt
in unsere Fußballfamilie holen da muss
man zwölf Jahre danach sagen und ja wir
haben uns über die Anzahl der Toten
gestritten dann muss man sagen das ist
gescheitert und mir später ein bisschen
die Rückkopplung das auch mal zuzugeben
zu sagen okay wir hatten vielleicht die
naive Ansicht wir holen Katar mit in die
Fußball-Familie und wollen offen dafür
sein aber wenn wir mal darüber
nachdenken dann sind da sehr sehr viele
Menschen gestorben und ich finde diese
Debatte auch zynisch da würde ich auch
Marcel Reif zustimmen ab wann gucken wir
denn die WM nicht mehr ab drei Toten ab
50 ab 60 ab 1.000 alleine dass wir
darüber reden müssen zeigt ja wie
verkommen das System ist und wie
verkommen diese Weltmeister
wir sind ja da auch als Medien manchmal
so klischeemaschinen und und an sich
selbst erhaltenes System und treiben
sozusagen die immer gleichen Argumente
dann manchmal wenn man nicht genau
hinguckt immer weiter voran und das kann
man an der Geschichte sehr gut sehen
finde ich und deswegen ist es schon
nicht unerheblich selbstverständlich ist
jeder einzelne tote wichtig das ist doch
gar keine Frage aber es ist nicht
unerheblich ob man sozusagen die immer
gleiche Zahl weiter kolportiert und
weiter trägt oder ob man irgendwann mal
die Frage stellt woher kommt denn diese
Zahl eigentlich das finde ich wichtig
ist aber ganz spannend ist wer die
Anzahl der Toten ja auch erfasst das ist
nämlich das
WM-Organisationskomitee aus Katar das
ist in etwa so als wenn die Kirche ihren
eigenen Missbrauchskandal untersucht ne
also da ist ja gar keine Neutralität
gegeben also sie sprechen ja offiziell
von von drei Toten die bei
Arbeitsunfällen das heißt von der Leiter
gefallen Fall auf dem Kopf und so weiter
ums Leben gekommen sind aber wenn man
mal glaube ich von diesen 15.000
Menschen ich glaube da gibt es auch
Statistiken das 70% junge Männer
Südasien sind ob es ein bisschen komisch
also hauptsächlich 25-jähriger
30-Jährige allein in aller Regel kein
Herzinfarkt
Herzversagen oder natürlicher Tod sind
die sind die üblichsten Todesursachen es
gibt auch die Zahl 6.500 die dann schon
etwas spezifischer ist man muss dazu
sagen dass aufgrund des externen Drucks
des Organisationskomitee schon in den
letzten Jahren verstärkt unter Druck
geraten ist auch wirklich die Zahlen
transparenter zu machen die Eröffnung
des Büros der io der Internationalen
Arbeitsorganisation 2018 in Katar hat
nicht alles zum Besseren geändert auf
gar keinen Fall aber sie hat zumindest
dazu geführt dass in Cutter selbst da
auch stärker und kritischer darüber
nachgedacht werden musste aber es ist
nicht auch so dass von Katar an die Geld
fließt 25 Millionen Euro das ist korrekt
dementsprechend sage ich auch das ist
nur die eine Seite der Medaille was aber
das Moment ist aufgrund der WM und das
nicht aufgrund der WM aufgrund des
Drucks der während der auf der wegen der
WM ausgeübt wird auf Qatar ist ein
kleines Land das nicht so ist wie China
oder Russland gezwungen sich stärker mit
dieser internationalen Kritik
auseinanderzusetzen das heißt nicht dass
die Reformen die ist auf dem Papier gab
umgesetzt werden und das liegt zum einen
daran dass eben ganz viele Menschen und
Akteure davon profitieren und zum
anderen weil es einfach ein
riesengeschäftsmodell wer soll denn
diesen erneuerungswillen von dem wer
hier sprechen wer soll denn den
umsetzen ja wir haben 300.000
privilegierte Kataris die dort leben
haben den Interesse daran dass der
fallersystem abzuschalten abzuschaffen
haben den Interesse daran für
Menschenrechte auf die Straßen zu gehen
es gibt keine NGOs es gibt keine freie
Presse es gibt keine Gewerkschaften das
heißt wenn es ein ehrliches Bedürfnis
eines erneuerungs gegeben hätte dann
hätte man den längst umsetzen können
aber keine WM und deswegen sage ich
nochmals und deswegen habe ich dir ihr
Hinweis eben ein bisschen irritiert Herr
Land wenn ich das mal so sagen darf dass
wir jetzt noch sagen ja toll die FIFA
hat fünf Jahre sechs Jahre danach
nachdem Menschenrechts Themen verankert
worden sind endlich reagiert nein ich
wollte das nicht das ist bitte
wir haben schon hier sehr kritisch mit
der FIFA beschäftigt und im besonderen
mit dem Herrn rechts im Bild da hinten
so habe ich nicht gemeint ich will es
einfach nur sagen da ist offenbar unter
internationalem Druck unter großer
Kritik ist ja irgendwann mal da aber was
passiert aber wir dürfen das nicht
drehen es sind ja die Toten sind der
entstanden weil sie unter anderem auf
einer Baustelle gearbeitet haben die ein
WM Stadion schafft und nicht so und die
Menschenrechtsverletzungen Marcel sind
Winkel kannst
das ist mir dann der Grund warum aber
das macht es doch nicht besser du hast
eben richtiger
der Sport hat nicht die Kraft hier
Gesellschaft zu verändern das heißt es
geht immer nur über die
Zivilgesellschaft und wenn wir jetzt
noch ja Steigbügelhalter sind durch
Sport washing für ein Regime was am Ende
auch nach innen wirkt
provoziert das ja die Frage ist das
richtig weil letztlich auch der katari
sagt ja Mensch ist ja alles so wunderbar
in Ordnung
was interessantes vor ungefähr
Viertelstunde haben sie den Begriff
sportwashing in die Runde geworfen so
nebenbei also sozusagen die Idee jetzt
bitte nicht als Vorwurf ja sondern
einfach nur als Argument und es ist ein
interessantes Argument weil es sozusagen
insinuiert der große Sport hält dafür
her dass wir uns reinwaschen können von
Menschenrechtsverletzungen von all den
Dingen die wir Missständen die wir
gerade besprechen meine These und da
will ich Sie gerne auch Fragen dazu weil
sonst ist eine andere wenn du dir eine
solche Vergabe holst wie auch immer dann
ist das ja das krasse Gegenteil von
sportswashing weil du richtest doch erst
recht den Scheinwerfer der ganzen Welt
richtest du auf dieses kleine Land jeder
guckt ganz genau hin und genau deswegen
machen wir jetzt auch diese Sendung das
heißt wenn da irgendjemand sich von
irgendwas reinwaschen wollte an dem
Punkt funktioniert das so nicht ich
glaube das ist genau das was die FIFA
und Katar am Anfang unterschätzt hat
also wenn man sich anschaut wie Katar
auf diese Art losgegangen ja in gewisser
Art und Weise ja zuerst gab es so eine
Phase der Ignoranz in den ersten Jahren
man wollte eigentlich gar nicht
wahrhaben dass es Kritik gibt dass es
massive Kritik gibt dann aufgrund dieser
Kritik musste catar reagieren wir können
darüber streiten und das ist auch stark
zu kritisieren was da am Ende bei
rumgekommen ist aber sie haben reagieren
müssen weil sie genau wussten dieses
sportswashing klappt so ohne weiteres
nicht was ist dann passiert vielleicht
können wir das einfach mal auch das für
das Protokoll mal festhalten sie sagten
gerade da ist nichts passiert ich kann
es nicht bewerten sie können es
vielleicht bewerten was ist denn
passiert in all diesen Jahren in diesen
zwölf Jahren Katar hat was jetzt die
Situation der Arbeitsmigranten und des
Arbeitsschutzes angeht bestimmte
gesetzlichen Regelungen erlassen die so
sagt das auch Katar in der Region
Pionierarbeit sind im Vergleich zu
Ländern wie Saudi-Arabien oder den
Vereinigten Arabischen Emiraten das
bedeutet dass der Mindestlohn angehoben
wurde dass Inspektion verbessert wurden
das vor allen Dingen aber auf die
wm-baustellen bezogen wird der
Mindestlohn sind zwei Euro 55 das ist
korrekt wo ist der Mindestlohn bei 2,55
Euro so und das umso ins relativ ins
Verhältnis setzen bei welchen
Lebenskosten welche also wir müssen uns
diese katarische Gesellschaft vorstellen
vielleicht mal so gefragt die katarische
Gesellschaft ist wird von außen als sehr
homogen dargestellt sie ist es nicht wir
haben 300.000 Staatsangehörige die einem
quasi in saust und rausläden das ist
eines der reichsten Länder der Welt die
katarischen Staatsangehörigen haben mit
das höchste Bruttoinlandsprodukt pro
Kopf der Welt dann haben wir Menschen
die hier sitzen die aus Europa aus den
anderen aus den USA kommen die dort sehr
gut verdienen gute Jobs haben die
sogenannten Expats die auch in so einer
eigenen Blase Leben und kaum eigentlich
mit katarischen Staatsangehörigen zu tun
haben jedenfalls sehr selten und dann
die große Gruppe etwa 1,8 bis 2
Millionen ArbeitsmigrantInnen aus
Ländern in Asien in Afrika die
tatsächlich unter sehr sehr prekären
Bedingungen leben und so wie so wie ich
das immer erlebt habe gibt es
wahrscheinlich auch da noch mal
Abstufungen oder dann gibt es dort am
unteren Ende stehen immer die Arme in
Afrikaner wir haben momentan auch so ein
Trend das sozusagen im Katar
asiatische ArbeitsmigrantInnen mit
afrikanischen sozusagen ausgetauscht
werden weil es am Ende des Tages die
afrikanischen noch günstiger sind was
die Drohne genau das Okay Lohndumping
und das ist mit Sicherheit auch noch mal
wichtig zu betonen dass innerhalb dieser
Migranten Community auch noch mal
unterschiedliche sozialer Hierarchien
existieren die zu Ausbeutung teilweise
auch zu Solidarität aber stärker zur
Ausbeutung führen könnten aber mal kurz
die Frage beantwortet Mindestlohn 2,55
was kann man damit anfangen also im
Verhältnis was heißt das im Verhältnis
bedeutet vor dass das prozentual etwa
zehnmal so viel ist wie wie im
Heimatland so 250 Euro verdient man ist
der Mindestlohn in Katar das ist immer
noch viel zu wenig darüber brauchen wir
nicht diskutieren
also ist ja kein Maßstab zu sagen dass
es dann im Heimatland noch schlechter
ist hat sie recht genau aber trotzdem
wichtig dass man einzuordnen also weil
es die Motivation erklärt warum die
Leute machen genau aber es ist
tatsächlich die Verhältnisse vor Ort
sind dann wie die Cutter ja im Kata sind
die Verhältnisse so dass viele Menschen
die auf den Baustellen gearbeitet haben
vor allen Dingen auch Hausangestellte
tatsächlich in sehr schlechten
Unterkünften leben dass sie keine
hygienischen Zugang zu hygienischen
Sanitäranlagen haben dass sie zum
Beispiel während Corona
angeschlossen wurden dann mehr schlecht
als recht mit nahrungs- und
medizinischen Mitteln versorgt wurden
also es ist wirklich eine katastrophale
Situation in der die meisten
ArbeitsmigrantInnen in worauf ich hinaus
will ist das Leben in Katar ist teuer
ist das vergleichbar mit den
Lebenshaltungskosten in Deutschland oder
wie wie ist das das Leben in Katha ist
ähnlich wie in Deutschland durch die
Inflation wird das noch teurer und das
hat selbstverständlich dann einen auch
ein Effekt das heißt 55 Mindestlohn
kommst du da nicht weit darauf will ich
hinaus genau das natürlich kommt man
damit nicht weit zu malen das muss man
berücksichtigen der große große Anteil
des Gehalts überweisen diese Menschen ja
an ihre Familien deswegen sind sie dort
und klar ist das kein moralisches
Argument zu sagen dass das Thema so viel
ist wie in ihren Heimatländern es ist
aber für diese Menschen tatsächlich eine
der wenigen Möglichkeiten auch der Armut
zu entfliehen